senator Sanders on his victory tonight
and I want to thank each and every one
of you and I want to say i still love
New Hampshire and I always
and here's what we're going to do now we
take this campaign to the entire country
we are going to fight for every vote in
every state
we're going to fight for real solutions
that make a real difference in people's
lives people have every right to be
angry but they're also hungry they're
hungry for solutions what are we going
to do
and that is that is the fight we're
taking to the country what is the best
way to change people's lives so we can
all grow together who is the best change
maker and here's what I promise here's
what I promise I will work harder than
anyone to actually make the changes that
make your lives better in this campaign
you've heard a lot about Washington and
about Wall Street now senator Sanders
and I both want to get secret
unaccountable money out of politics and
let's remember let's remember citizens
united one of the worst Supreme Court
decisions in our country's history was
actually a case about a right wing
attack on me and my campaign a
right-wing organization took aim at me
and ended up damaging our entire
democracy so yes you're not going to
find anybody more committed to
aggressive campaign finance before than
me we also have to break through the
barriers of bigotry african-american
parents shouldn't have to worry that
their children will be harassed
humiliated even shot because of the
color of their skin
to everyone who went to Hillary Clinton
calm to give what you could for that
700,000 people have contributed to this
campaign the vast majority giving less
than a hundred dollars I know that
doesn't fit with the narrative I know
there are those who want to deny the
passion and the purpose you all show
every day for this campaign but you are
the reason we are here and you are the
reason we are going to win the
nomination and then with this election
together thank you all
so very much
you